i'm going to be a dad yeah it's going to
be amazing congratulations thank you i'm
really really we're both really really
happy john mullaney confirms his
girlfriend olivia munn is pregnant i
want entertainment tonight to tell the
entire world yep the 39 year old
comedian confirmed he and the 41 year
old actress who he started dating
earlier this year are having a baby
together it's exciting john joined
longtime friend seth meyers on tuesday's
late night and opened up about his
challenging year which included a drug
relapse rehab and a divorce from anna
marie tendler i went to rehab in
september okay i got out in october
i move out of my home from my ex-wife
you and some other friends staged an
intervention as you recall i went to
rehab again i got out in february i
lived in sober living for another month
and a half then in the spring i went to
los angeles and
met and started to date a wonderful
woman named olivia she's kind of held my
hand through that hell
and we're having a baby he later
reflected on how olivia is helping him
stay sober and healthy as he recovers
and battles his addiction olivia and
this baby have helped save me from
myself and
this early
journey out of recovery
news of their romance first broke in may
shortly after e.t confirmed john and his
wife of six years had split
back in 2019 when olivia was in a
relationship with tucker roberts she
opened up to e.t about her outlook on
kids and marriage i have two dogs two
cats so that's a lot i mean i don't have
kids i can't i mean honestly it's a lot
i really
kind of
come to a realization with myself that
i'm i'm already
in my happily ever after and that's you
know and if i want to have kids or want
to get married then you know i'll do
that but it has to add to my life you
know i've already loved my life as it is
like i've got amazing girlfriends i've
got my pets i've got my career i'm
really really happy and you know
anything else that wants to come into my
life has to add
[Music]
you